[موسيقى]
مؤلف أجنبي لكتاب طبخ أطباق البحر الأبيض المتوسط
اليوم لدي بعض النصائح البسيطة
حول كيفية اختيار البطيخ المثالي.
لقد تعلمت كيفية اختيار
البطيخ المثالي من والدي عندما كان في منطقة الحرير
في بورسايد مصر عندما كنت
صغيرًا جدًا، فإليك  فقط بعض النصائح البسيطة
التي تعلمتها منه، النصيحة الأولى
تتعلق بالحجم والوزن، لذا عندما
ترفع البطيخة إذا كانت أثقل بالنسبة
لحجمها، فهي
النصيحة الثانية، إذا كانت البطيخة
مناسبة تمامًا، فيجب أن تعطيك القليل منها
صوت أعمق
مقابل هذا الذي لا أعتقد أنه
صحيح جدًا،
حسنًا، إذا لم ينجح ذلك بالنسبة لك،
سأعطيك النصيحة الثالثة
وهي النصيحة الأكثر أهمية من بين النصائح الثلاثة التي
تبحث عنها  البطيخ الذي يحتوي على
بشرة داكنة جدًا من جانب واحد ولكن بعد ذلك
تريد أن تكون قادرًا على رؤية ما أسميه
البقعة الصلعاء والتي هي في الواقع بقعة
الحقل تخبرك أنه كان لديه ما يكفي من
الوقت للجلوس في الحقل تحت أشعة الشمس
تقشعر لها الأبدان حتى كان  جاهز، أعتقد أن هذا
فائز،
رائع للغاية، إنه أحمر للغاية، إنه
ثقيل، إنه حلو وعصير، هذا هو
البطيخ الذي سيقابل العائلة،
هذه هي النصائح الثلاث التي آمل أن تكون
مفيدة إلى اللقاء